[Music]
they're funny and enlightening and
always out there fighting the jokes can
be quite biting the mug Club family the
Studio's quite Hy and if if you hate it
we got new merch to show the the mug
Club
family
mugs
shirts hats so fill that giry mug up
pick up your shirt from the shop watch
us as we scale up the M Club
family head over to crowers shop.com to
check out all the new designs order now
and get $5 free no minimum purchase
today only that's crowers
shop.com
[Music]
[Applause]
spooky I
[Music]
got that was a good one I got good uh is
it torque traction what do you call it
what do you call it is it suction power
I don't know you can comment below but
hey tomorrow is our annual Halloween
Spooktacular so if you post your
Halloween costume send it to me on
Instagram or Twitter your mug has to be
in the picture use a #t Spooktacular you
are going to get a well you're going to
get a prize that's bigger than just a
swag bag really yeah yeah maybe maybe a
truck that's right right we do have that
so we have a lot to get to today and I
have still have a little bit of a cold
that's moved into my ears so everything
sounds
like but cold moved into your ears
that's how I feel about today's
stories Gavin Nome
look you can bring up the rundown here
he's in China you guys know you know he
beat up a kid okay that's kind of funny
but I think it's
important to contrast his policy which
is very similar to Biden's policy on
China versus Donald Trump there is a
very if you're not talking about taxes
if you're not talking about drag queen
Story Hour if you're just talking about
the issue of dealing with China in their
track record you have a very very clear
contrast and a choice to make and that
choice is I I leave the choice to you
the people then we're going to be
talking about uh the dagistan airport
Riot I don't not so much as a riot as a
you know the Dag and he seeking out Jews
to kill yeah it's different than a riot
yeah a little bit different than a riot
and it brings us to a major point that
everywhere across the Muslim world you
have people uh committing gross acts of
I don't want to say anti-Semitism
because that whitewashes anti-jew
anti-jew wanting to kill Jews and we're
going to be looking at you know the ISL
is there anywhere in the Islamic world
that you would want to live not we're
not talking about in the United States
where they make a very small minority
anytime Muslims islamists in the world
reach a majority and control government
human rights
die that's an important point that I
think people need to understand here
it's not just we're not just talking
about Gaza we're not just talking about
turkey we're not just talking about
Jordan Lebanon we're talking about all
of them ever right and you can comment
below if you can think of a place where
that's not the case say a ran in the 70s
and test my
patients just give it a decade and they
screw up then we're also going to get
into what we know about Mike Johnson
because a lot of people are hey who
who's Mike Johnson right myself included
and I do this lived I said
who so comment below we're going to get
into all of these topics China the Jews
how you feel about them keep it you know
YouTube friendly I guess Gerald CEO
number two I just wanted to hey hold on
a second look it's riffraff on CNN oh my
God what is that time is
fleeting very do we have sound can you
not bring up sound fastly by the
Israelis in in coming days though
Russia's ambassador to Israel that's
like a guy who started a combover and
gave up Midway
through he's like I wanted a combover
but I also want to be an Emo
Kid Gerald how are you I'm just sorry
it's very distracting when I have CNN a
guy looks that bizarre it's true I
understand I'm doing well how are you
I'm fine yeah little you know it's just
like it's just the C it's completely out
of my sinuses thanks to the the clear
you know it's a spot they're not spot
today but I use it it always clears out
in my nose and my throat completely but
then it's in my ears so huh what
speaking of which I'm not speaking of
which but uh when you hear this can we
you guys can hear it I can't hear
anything because of my ears don't worry
Yakuza it's not you thank you you know
him you love him November 9th 10th and
11th he's going to be at good nights in
uh Raleigh North Carolina you can see
all of his other dates at Brian ken.com
and of course off limits here on mug
Club on Tuesdays Mr Ken how are you I'm
fine my friend my ears are not full of
mucus Charlie good nights uh it was
Charlie good nights and they changed it
to good nights so I'm glad you cleared
it up
people would be looking for Charlie and
they're not it's yeah put that in your
ways hey good night I thought you're
supposed to be a Jack In The Box my name
is Charlie it's an awkward name it's
like Ruth's Chris Steakhouse yeah hey
make up your mind I know I know not to
be confused with Ruth's tits strip clo
but the good news is my comedy's a lot
like a steak huh
juicy overcooked you mean it's more like
come on it's like an earlys come on pair
of sweatpants with that written across
you know when people say that about my
comedy I get into cut up oh really he
goes off limits hey by the way if you
watching on YouTube of course you know
we have a partnership with Rumble mug
Club is Rumble Rumble is mug Club but if
you're still watching on YouTube at some
point today you'll likely see
this that means we're not going to self
censor and just you should watch it on
Rumble anyway that probably smelled like
if you could smell it's it's coffee
beans on fire that probably smells
pretty good oh well we turned on the
heat today because it got cold and I was
like did someone burn their hair I know
first time you turn on the heat you're
like oh I'm burning
arbody burn their hair the first time
you smell burned hair you never forget
it I was S I was reading next to a lamp
and this was before you know this is an
old school incandescent yeah and I just
like what and then I noticed smoke and I
burned a hole through my really that's
why I use nare really instead of a
lighter when I want to take my chest fur
down well chest fur I wasn't saying I
used a lighter deliberately I don't
think actually does that that's more of
a fetish hey right speaking of I guess
let's say dumb things
uh here is a black kid sorry I want to
be I want to be respectful this is a a
criminal of color a
future lifetime incarcerated lowlife
doctor of color Yes lawyer uh future
pratton Whitney engineer of color so
here's uh remember that black kid who
sucker punched the guy in the Park yeah
and it went viral he was playing The
Knockout game and he failed well the
problem is you know people were really
upset about it but more importantly you
you don't always remember how it affects
real folks he played The Knockout game
people were upset here's
said child of color upset about people
being upset 19-year-old Alfred Lewis
spoke with me about how he feels about
it now you know I just made a mistake
and everybody makes mistakes this is the
video in question first shared with kh1
via the next door app in it you can
clearly see Lewis striking a man in the
head from behind I see him making a m
turn around and shock I know like from
the video all you see is like the bad
part about
it um what people didn't see was that I
shook his hand after I gave the man a
hug how can we miss that is something we
cannot verify more than we that another
man video getting punched and grabbed
later left on good terms according to
Lewis I really didn't expect for it to
just go so left you
know so you made a mistake with the
punch son but what about the attempted
poorly attempted suplex I mean I forgot
you was
perfect yeah but sometimes when you
forgot you never made a mistake we was
cool he was cool why you not why why
aren't you cool because you punched a
random man for no reason and tried to
suplex him into the concrete ah it's a
race thing you could have but sometimes
when you like somebody in the playground
you hit them first so when you're four
yes yes we hurt the ones we love we hurt
the ones we love we commit want
violence strangers they see the good
part they didn't see the good part of my
hay maker my random a that's that's what
happens when you are raised with
entitlement and you can do no wrong from
birth what people don't see is I shook
his hand okay that's less the headline
than you punched an old man at random in
the face as far as I'm concerned people
like this deserve uh attempted murder I
was about to say any idea how many times
people hit concrete that's exactly right
we've had video of that where a guy he
got hit with the skateboard hit his head
on the concrete now he he can't walk or
he can't function I can't remember
exactly what it was but it was terrible
if he had landed the blow from behind
and actually knocked the guy out face
first into the pavement I'm sorry I
didn't you know what I did yeah well
that would be the part that the media
would show you what they didn't show you
was afterwards I sent the mother Tiff
streets see I feel like you're I Sher
berries up in that but they don't
show you that yeah but why is why is
Steven's impression of a a 40-year-old
black man who's actually you
know car it's a good car I tell you that
it's like hey hold on no yours is a
yours is an early 20th century like
slave early 19th century slave okay I'm
not gonna get into that yes I play The
Knockout game so I do try to punch him
with the left hook balls I reject that
you're one of the crows from Dumbo hey
you know what this is one of what's
what's crazy is when you go and look at
the reactions is the racial divide now
the vast majority of black people like
this kid is a dumbass but there are
enough that it's alarming going oh man
it's just differences in culture well
then that's a bad culture I I love the
victim response I the media didn't show
you that we was cool after yeah maybe he
acted like he was cool because he was
terrified from the violent assault yes
yeah yes yeah and also maybe he got
caught and that's why he didn't see the
good part yeah I cuz I got behind him I
did get behind him and I locked my arms
and I I dry humped him a little bit as
he kept walking my and then I shook his
hand it would be great if he tries that
on some Eastern European wrestler who
reverses the suplex and sends him for
like man why you got to do that though
yeah yeah the guy I didn't see his chin
strapped beard and no mustache uhoh I
should have known by the Adidas
tracksuit and gold
chain and it had he had his name on the
back yonko it's it said yonko I I I've
learned my lesson not to try sulex Yono
yo what is this game you play Americans
all
right
okay anyways you guys can I just find it
so fun I thought the story was done I
did and people reacted and then he was
upset like just go away this is one of
those just apologize period not I'm
sorry but no no no no you're about to
make a mistake just stop I'm sorry okay
anything that you speak anything you
utter after the words I'm sorry is a
mistake it would just make this worse
must be nice to have such privilege okay
let's go go with that all right uh
remember Mike Pence yeah so he
announced that he's pulling out of the
presidential race good Pence is the
first major candidate to leave the race
which continues to be dominated by his
former boss Donald Trump this comes
after his campaign for the White House
struggle to raise money or gain Traction
in the poll now I I the mission control
can bring this up for me I'm pretty sure
that he actually performed more poorly
than any former vice presidential
candidate since Dan Quail I know what
you're thinking but in 2000 when Quail
ran in
2000 Mike Pence did worse well after the
quail name he did worse than quail in
2000 well and just to be clear I think
that's it's kind of a misleading Intro
by the reporter the first major
candidate to drop out I would not
consider him major ex probably with like
2% you must be at least this High to run
for office he was worried he wasn't even
going to make the next debate he
wouldn't clear the hurdles that were
basically put in to keep Chris Christie
out and he had a great on liner he's
like oh I have that jerk store line so
in honor of uh Pence's exit uh we give
him this is actually rare we've never
done this a second edition because we
did it before he ran predicting that of
course he would lose uh this is a second
edition of time to close bias against
minorities is is a great
insult to the men and women who serve in
law
enforcement remember $2 a gallon gas I
do and then Joe Biden became president
of the United States and launched his
war on
energy time to
close endings and Beginnings are ending
are billions of us tax dollars don't
have enough tanks I think it's a fair
question to ask like where's the concern
for the United States in that well it's
not my
concern my wife uh isn't a member of the
teachers union but I got to admit I
I've been sleeping with a teacher for 38
years and um a full
disclosure the time has come for our
European Partners to withdraw from the
Iran nuclear deal and join with us as we
bring the economic and diplomatic
pressure necessary to give the Iranian
people the region and the world the
peace security and freedom they
deserve I know that it's time for things
to
close I know that it's time for things
[Music]
close yeah you won't be missed yeah that
clip brought to you by Charisma
vacu the black hole of Charisma ladies
the cancer of charm he's a man but God
yeah he's just terrible at this game the
next time I need white noise or more
that clip about Mike Pence giving a
speech oh there's nothing worse than
waiting for an Applause break and you
can see on his face that he still has
more speech and he wants to check out
[Music]
he amazing that was my best material
ohow man that was my a material he's
looking down at his C material he's like
son of a it's going to be a long one I
and he paused he knew it wasn't going to
I admit I F I sleeping with it ah never
mind sleeping with it I've been sleeping
with it
teacher damn it thank you ladies and
gentlemen thank you much thank I'm going
to go enjoy your fruit compo I'll be
here all week speaking of someone who's
also very cringey uh and looks like
they're out of Central Casting but has
nothing to offer okay I want to talk
about not only Gavin Newsome first off
let me ask you and we asked this a long
time ago not a long a few weeks ago yeah
do you think that Biden is going to be
the candidate no think he's going to be
the candidate for the the uh Democratic
party or do you think that it will be
someone else do you think it will be gav
a lot of people think that I know
Patrick Bet David thinks it will be
Gavin Newsome I know Gerald does I made
that call before Patrick Bet David I
think okay look come on now Gerald say
honest be honest going to try and say
that he said it before me let me put it
to you that way all right Gerald right
he's a guy who says okay I predict it
first but if you look at it he has a 60%
chance of predicting at first okay I
have a 70% chance but then of my 70% I
use 20 he only uses 10 that means I
predicted at first Gerald is a guy with
small biceps I have the biggest biceps
that you do have big biceps I put it to
you that
way okay so Gavin
Newsome here's the thing he he he has a
different code of paint he's not very
different from Joe Biden no in as a
matter of policy certainly as it relates
to China and this is where we have a
very very STK contrast I mean we've had
eight years of Obama three years of
Donald Trump really will have had four
years of Biden and you'll get to see the
difference in the economy you'll get to
see the difference in unrest
internationally but I also think it's
important to see the difference in our
posturing as we go into uh really the
new it's not new but the technological
age really that's an arms race right now
and China is a big problem some people
would argue so Gavin Nome uh just um is
I guess he just emerged but not really
it seems like he might be running here's
a clip that maybe hints at it and we'll
get into it this is a guy look I mean he
no is he is he going to challenge Joe
Biden in a primary probably not but it's
hard to imagine this isn't somebody
who's sort of waiting and watching and
wants to be available on deck if
sometime in the next year uh Joe Biden
isn't running okay so he has the second
best odds of winning the Democratic
nomination there are a bunch of
headlines out there speculating that he
might run he was pressed on the question
last month and he kind of gave an answer
but then if you understand what he's
doing traveling abroad uh in China it
it's it's one of those how often have we
heard I'm not running I'm not running
I'm not running until they run so this
is from about uh a month ago or within
the last month I think we need to move
past this notion that he's not going to
run President Biden is going to run uh
and looking forward to getting him
reelected uh I think there's been so
much wallowing uh in the last few months
and hand ringing in this respect uh but
we're gearing up for the campaign we're
looking forward to it I I you know but
you hear these calls privately what do
you tell these donors who are wallowing
uh time to move on let's
go there's so pauses the only good thing
about that interview I think that was
Chuck Todd's last or very close to last
interview before he signed off was
replaced then he got he probably got a
show on HBO Max yeah probably yeah I
think I think Nome is gonna run not this
time because California is too much of a
liability but but I but this is kind of
how you set up your Camp campaign from
four years from now you kind of stick
your head out and you're like hello I'm
just here look I'm going to visit China
I think it's more than that like some of
his behavior like he's he went to the uh
the RNC he went de Republican debate
yeah he tried to he tried to debate what
was it vivec no or uh DeSantis I think
DeSantis he took some shots at vivec he
he's publicly attacked Governors like
you know like Abbott which by the way is
in poor taste cuz he's a wheelchair guy
that's generally speaking non-
wheelchair guys shouldn't attack
wheelchair guys don't punch down he's
gone after Dan santis as well um and he
uh he's been trying to do some political
sort of stag like he vetoed the trans
kid custody Bill uh that we talked about
he's been doing this media BL yeah yeah
so I definitely think that he's probably
he's in the mix I think if nothing else
he's probably planning on a cabinet
position yeah yeah there there are a
number of things that he could do but
look Brian to your point when people
look at him and go oh he's just
preparing for whenever Biden is done in
28 I'm like this is too early for that
yeah exactly you know he's doing way
like if he was doing a handful of things
over the course of a year fine he's
doing way too many things back to back
to back to back to back back to tell us
like hey I'm trying to do something
bigger than just in well for him big and
I don't know if you know this but
everything is bigger in China they say
no it's
the nothing's bigger than I mean the
land mass is very large it's the
oppression it keeps the people which is
maybe why is bigger maybe the Chinese
people are not as Tiny as they seem it's
just it's the scale they look tiny in
this large length no they're also very
tin but there's like 20 billion of them
so it would just be like World War Z if
there was a World War they' be throwing
CCP leaders we have a
clip oh there we go nice pick nice pick
bam bam
bam I got you I got you tackle
basketball's tackle sorry that was him
being creepy and harming a child a
Chinese child in a basketball court now
I will be it's obviously knocked the kid
by accident and he was trying to soften
it but if they were playing by their own
rules you know patting a a Chinese kid
on the ass who was likely a prisoner of
the government three times wouldn't go
over wouldn't go over very well it was
the small of his back guys seriously no
it was really it was not the small of
his back it was
Alli and if that were Donald Trump he'd
hit him you know go get
up pull a great San you going to cry huh
cry cry CRA it's an obvious charge as
well I apologize for the wrong clip but
it's fun for me here's the right one
Nome arrived to China on Monday visiting
several major cities and provinces among
the stops a tour of an electric bus
depot in Shenzhen and a visit to the
Great Wall that's a photo not a photo a
Chinese bus he inspected the bus line
officials in beijing's office say the
discussion focused on climate change
economic ties between China and
California and by the way just to note
American reporters they were not allowed
in the meeting at all uh so let me give
you a recap of what he did on his visit
and then kind of show you the concerns
that I would have of Nome but also Biden
with China that's something that's sort
of being overlooked right now because of
the conflict with you know Israel and
Hamas so what did he do he discussed
climate change with Chinese thank God
that'll cool the planet that'll cool the
planet yeah yeah exactly and what the CH
of course J ping you know he wrote down
notes and then immediately threw them
out yeah shred I was going to say the
Chinese poll Bureau isn't like listen
guys we had we got a visit from the
California governor good guy and uh I I
feel like he inspected our our bus lines
played basketball with the kids and
let's stop let's let's practice fair
trade practice and and and maybe not spy
on them as much yeah hey we talk with
gavan maybe we shouldn't burn body of
weager for for energy no no more Burning
Body go back to Cole baby step that
maybe Clean Coal less coal less coal and
well we're still burn body recycle
recycle burn
body he visited a Tesla Factory in
Shanghai he rode you saw him there in
the bus but he also rode some high-speed
trains so that's impressive there you go
thank God there you go that's not safe
that's not safe for people on audio it's
worse than you think now and if you're
not subscribed on audio do consider you
know Spotify Apple Google Stitcher
wherever you listen to audio podcasts uh
head on over there because that also
helps with the algorithm there so I
don't know if you have that to no all
right no so we have a question why did
Gavin Newsome go to China all right well
we kind of have some answers um he told
CNN when talking about China that quote
divorce is not an option when speaking
of the economic relationship between the
United States and China and he said that
the US and China were quote
interdependent now let me give you some
ex first off California needs Chinese
money right they need it for investment
of H you know the viewership of
Hollywood films you look at like you
wonder why there's Fast and Furious
they're very big in China exactly which
I hate them for more than just about
anything else yeah or the Meg to they've
ruined like do we really need the Meg to
no they had to change Red Dawn so you
had John Cena apologizing John Cena was
apologizing to China for acknowledging
Taiwan as a place oh 100% he he would
not work Richard Gear they say stop
being a movie star cuz he made that
speech back in the 9s about Tibet and
they were like we'll see you later dude
oh how do you feel about Geral yeah well
no Stallone made that up so uh they're
also huge buyers the Chinese of major
buyers of California real estate right
um oops uh they also need China for
their domestic market like thing
companies like apple like jet California
is very interdependent on China okay
also I'm not a complete isolationist uh
when we're talking about uh trade
internationally the issue is that we
have been engaging in trade with China
where it has not been fair right it has
not been an equitable arrangement and
believe me I know for example there's no
place to get our mugs made in the United
States there's not an American company
that can make these mugs so we have it
hand etched and painted in the United
States sometimes there are supply issues
so I don't believe in punishing American
businesses for needing supplies that
cannot come from the United States that
being said there are a lot of companies
out there like apple like we insert
whatever Nike insert whatever Factory of
the day and some of them I get are
Bangladesh and some of them are other
places Vietnam but a lot of them are in
China where they simply want to cut
costs and use slave labor California is
one of the worst offenders if you look
at the companies who benefit from this
okay and by the way you can join mug
Club let cutter.com mug club and you get
Brian show on Tuesday you get Nick
depalo every day 5:00 pm you get a full
extra hour of show Alex Jones guns and
gear Hodge twins okay speaking of the
test fat Tesla now I have Patrick M
David okay all
right let me break it down for you okay
so speaking of the Tesla Factory right
we have a Tesla Factory I want to make
cars okay I say have to make cars I want
to make the best cars but I have to cut
costs right if it's 60% Tesla it's 60%
lithium batteries I need 40% nickel then
I need 20% of cadium guess what I'm
going to
China that makes sense yeah Patrick says
it you're like that's why I put it to
you that way
so the Tesla Factory in China is
interesting because Nome made these
comments he said the advantages here are
self-evident in terms of Supply chains
it is a benefit to both countries and
certainly to the state of California
huh you mean the the car company that
left your state because of your
crippling regulations and had to come to
Texas not just a car company the
electric car company for which you
provided additional Financial incentives
if you can't make an electric car
company work in California you cannot
make it work can't be
done oh wait wait hold on a second
that's right you guys are hypocrites
it's just about money so it's just
interesting to me that the guy who did
more for the electric car than anyone in
modern history had to leave the
eco-friendly State of California right
right so here he is saying that this is
a good thing the supply chain issues and
also was going wait hold a second don't
they have don't they have factories in
the United States Tesla MH so that's a
perfect example of a company that
doesn't need to be in China Gavin new is
saying it's better for us if part of it
is in China than in California the
opposite of America First this is right
in line with of course whether he's the
candidate or not Biden Newsome
completely interchangeable they're soft
on soft on China policies I've said we
are for drisking not decoupling with
China we will push back on aggression
and intimidation and defend the rules of
the road from freedom of navigation to
overflight to level economic playing
field that have helped Safeguard
security always looks like he's looking
into the
sun work together like a bad CL Ewood
he's staring into hell on our common
efforts and your is
uncontroversial should Thrive and um it
would really be disaster ous to try to
decouple from
China were you about to say something
there
Jill there's a lot of things that I was
about to say I just hate that that clip
from Joe Biden makes us look like one of
the weakest countries on the planet when
you're talking about China I understand
the decoupling comments like we have to
use them for some things I get it but at
the same time you have to understand
that these guys will never play by any
International rules that do not benefit
them they do not care what you think
they know their position right now and
the more that you give them strength the
more they're going to do that the more
you take that away from them the more
they're like well hold on let's talk
about this yes and that's not what we've
been doing with Biden or anybody else
from the Democrats yeah well our entire
lives my entire life growing up everyone
who wanted to fancy themselves an
economist would say well you know the
future is China it's all exactly except
for really three years pre-co yeah when
Donald Trump was President people going
oh maybe they are a paper tiger wait a
second maybe we don't have to cow out
them it's not I have no problem with
another country doing well honestly I
have a problem with a communist Nation
stealing from the United States
subjugating their own we need to be we
need to be honest about that you can't
about violations of rights for
example in Gaza on behalf of Israel and
say that you know our relationship with
China is really important yeah well
that's the problem that I had with the
NBA and with Nike and with apple was
that they were doing those things in the
United States they were complaining
about human rights abuses they were
trying to jump on every woke thing that
they possibly could and then turning a
blind eye that what was to what was
happening in China where their products
are being made or where their services
are being sold or where people were
watching their games for crying out loud
people couldn't even have signs here in
the United States criticizing China when
we have free speech it took a long time
to get all that stuff online that
symbiotic relationship between America
and the United St and China is is is
decades in the making so getting off
that is going to take a little time I
feel like politicians are just buying
time yeah like China has so many
problems not just a demogra demographic
problem but entrepreneurs and people are
leaving China all like Hong Kong is
paying people to have children they're
literally saying we'll give you $2500
for every kid you have and and you'll
get an apartment fact which is not a bad
deal n not which just tells me how
unattractive women must be in Hong
Kong we'll pay you to bang what we'll
pay you to bang you bang go bang bang
bang I give you money bring receipt a
bang bang her give me a no no no no
don't no American Girl I bang I bang I
bang She Bangs Swedish I take UK Cran
[Laughter]
I'm sure I'm sure the women are
beautiful in Hong Kong that's right my
point is you shouldn't have to pay men
to have sex with
them so let's contrast that with whether
you like him hate him I think if nothing
else Donald Trump was pretty clear as to
his stance on China well the reaction is
very simple China has been taken
advantage of the United States for many
many years I'm not just talking about
doing the Obama Administration why do
you keep using this
racist it's not racist at all no not at
all it comes from China That's why comes
from China to decades later this theory
has been tested and proven completely
wrong not only has China declined to
adopt promised reforms it has embraced
an economic model dependent on massive
Market barriers heavy State subsidies
currency manipulation product dumping
Force technology transfers and the theft
of intellectual
property and also trade secrets on a
grand scale he needs more orange around
the eyes also they built a they built a
trap one time my fingers couldn't take
them
out the trickery I didn't until they
said use your thumbs and you push you
push it out but why make a trap like
that there's no
purpose purposeless Jenny's
trap so
a purposeless Chinese trap that's what
it is that's what listen folks a lot of
people say I would never say this it's
just a purposeless Chinese
trap it's also like that thing you grab
from Dollar Tree where you keep grab but
it keeps slipping out of your hands
there's no way to get a
grip I'm in a trap why there's no
purpose I would imagine that Donald
Trump is the kind of guy who hates
practical
jokes and just dissects them why would
you do this banana peel again yeah why
is your hand electrical let she have a
buzzer oh we're all laughing what a
great joke are you in the third
grade whoopy cushions he
laughs he said that to an eight-year-old
so so this is the contrast here is you
have an entire party who is not just
saying hey we need to be realistic about
our relationship with China they want to
increase our codependency with China
yeah um to a degree that is alarming you
have Gavin new right now he wants to
increase his National profile profile
and so he's going to China which just
seems a little bit weird he's courting
Chinese money um he's basically the
Chinese candidate and I would say the
same thing about Joe Biden meanwhile
China taking a little bit of a different
TCT as it relates uh to the United
States
so basically for people who are
listening on audio who aren't watching
this he's talking about complete
Independence for China not being Reliant
to the United States not allowing for uh
American interference again they don't
view nationalism as a racist term there
um they just view it as being a good
Chinese Citizen and it's also how you
know that uh their media is entirely
government propaganda because no
reporter who looks like that would be
allowed in American Media he looks he
looks like a a children's doll who was
given a haircut can we bring up
a yes there you
go yeah he's just like kill me kill me
kill me please cut it like a child when
you can't make like a child and cut my
hair but people are forgetting about the
Chinese the the Chinese conflict here
forgetting about I mean and this by the
way this this lurks behind all of it
when you look at Putin and you look at
what he's talking about when you look at
you know these meetings with Hamas
Representatives if you're talking about
Russia you see how that relationship is
cozing up far more than it used to be
China and Russia and you see how
everyone is discussed well everyone used
to say that China was going to be the
next great superpower Donald Trump said
absolutely not and we said I guess not
now the Democrats are they want you to
act like that was just a skip in the
record no no they're going to be the
world's next big superpower so we might
as well be on board with it yeah exactly
and and look there are a lot of
indicators right now that China is not
going to continue to rise in power and
people just keep overlooking that and I
don't know why that would be a good
thing for the world if all the sudden
China is diminished in power and
standing but the United States current
Administration keeps doing things to
bolster their standing to keep pushing
other people into their arms whether
they want to be or not China and Russia
are not natural friends they have no
military Alliance right now what is
probably going to happen is China is
going to be friends with them just so
that they can take their resources from
Russia and Russia can't do anything stop
China when they want to do that right
China is playing 8D chess and right now
Joe Biden's playing checkers and this is
going to get us into a lot of trouble
especially if a Democrat somehow steals
the election again and ends up in office
in 24 it's just going to be more of the
same that's right you're allowed to
question election results we are now I
wouldn't do I wouldn't you guys don't
need to hit the YouTube dump button I
wouldn't I wouldn't get us a strike I
mean I would but I would got us so many
strikes so all right like strikes
they're fun by the way hey can I give
just a clarification it's a little worse
than you thought 8,000
cash equivalent gift for each of the
first two children in Hong Kong that's
what parents get not 2500
$88,000 her child American her child up
up to two yeah so maybe once you get to
three they don't really care but yeah in
California that pays for your first two
months yeah exactly think about that
people are there are probably people
paying that much for a high-end
prostitute in Nevada somewhere they're
going to pay you to have sex with your
own wife or someone else some they just
need a baby yeah they don't care as long
as it's not a weager yes well I'm just
saying it's on the question people want
to about civil rights in the
United States hey these children can't
take puberty blockers at 6 years old
meanwhile you get imprisoned in China if
you're a weager who won't sell
cigarettes at your Bodega that's true
okay well you just have to video the sex
to prove it though so do you no I'm just
kidding think about how would they
confirm it have to do is there like a
there's like a Hong Kong Mory yeah Ching
Wang how do you think they pay for it
they you are the
father oh no wait I get child support I
I get money okay
yay I my pH I think I'm going to make a
prediction I think China is going to
have to import young people to support
their old people and their economy and
those young people are going to come
from Africa and India yeah and uh except
the Chinese people are very racist so
they will not like that but you know
what when that gets into the genan pool
it's hard to stop people do mingle when
Big Brother isn't watch
I'm just saying be be ready because I'm
sorry but black and Chinese makes for
very good looking they do make for very
good very good oh yes yes oh yes oh yeah
mhm it's a beautiful it's a beauti combo
you guys obviously have no $6,000 credit
needed none uhuh no say no more that's
what I'm saying serve my country let's
move on to another country before we get
to Mike Johnson dagistan and I know what
you're thinking there are some wrestlers
from there pretty much it that's their
export that in hate yes that's the only
two things they have contributed to the
world now this is important to note uh
we've talked about this before if you go
back to the Quran challenge uh um and
dagistan is interesting because it's not
necessarily what you think of when you
think of the Islamic
world you can't judge uh the progression
of Islam by minorities in the United
States or in Canada for example where
they are a minority of the citizenship
you kind of have to judge Islam as far
as its performance historically when
nation is a majority islamist and they
gain control of the government no maybe
you can name to me any place on earth
that is a muslimun government that does
not violate human and civil rights to a
degree that would be abor here in the
United States comment below if you can
think of what because that's what brings
us to something that is not all that
surprising to people in places like
dagistan but in the United States you
might say oh I I I never knew this so an
angry mob of Muslims in dagistan Russia
they formed uh I guess you would call it
I guess a Lynch Mob Chain Gang that's
exactly right yeah looking for and this
isn't just a protest they were actually
seeking out an alleged flight of of Jews
from Israel to try and well in their own
words kill
them
Allah
[Applause]
these are children listening on audio
came for the Jews to kill them what will
you kill them with a
knife huh
now that terminal is still safer than
that of Spirit Airlines here in
Texas 60 people were arrested in the
let's not call it Riot let's call it uh
attempted murder of Jews used to be if
you wanted to kill Jews in an airport
you'd have to connect in Fort Lauderdale
and now you just hey D Works D I guess
it's a country where the national sport
is MMA I I want to say something the
national sport is beating Jews well yes
je Jew hunting is also huge it's very
large but if I may I think if you are
Jewish and you caught you're caught in
dagistan because it's not a it's not a
great vacation spot but they do have
nice they have nice mountains they their
tourism campaign is better than the
actual if you want to brush up on your
takedown defense or your your single leg
it's a good place to go if you are in
situation like that and a mob in
dagistan comes at you and you're Jewish
what you want to do is throw books at
them and they will scatter the way mice
do I'm sorry elephants do when they see
mice so that's what I right so it's kind
of like with the leprechaun if you throw
shoes shoes he has to Cobble he has to
Cobble it's a compulsion yeah and like
dagistan have to run away from books
well in that situation yes in that sit I
don't know I I don't know if that's I
don't have the data on that but I'm
pretty sure there was another there was
a hotel by the way in dagistan uh um
yeah that was searched for Jews by Angry
locals they they were just looking
through by the way if you are if you're
a decent person in dagistan and you have
Jews in your hotel and angry Muslims
like don't don't tell
them yeah you don't know maybe we have
we have Jews here don't tell them like
if if someone and by the way that
applies also in Dearborn if you're in
Lebanon like if you're a decent person
even if you're a Muslim but you don't
want to see Jews killed if they come
like you will tell me what every last
Jew is don't no well it was a George
Soros owned Hotel though so yeah he like
Jews on every floor there just a holog
hand D I think I think it's seriously
yeah I think it's seriously significant
though that we live in 2023 Jews are
actually having to hide in this country
being told not to go outside in Flatbush
Brooklyn but certainly everywhere in
Islamic uh countries I mean think about
that they're looking for Jews in a hotel
and it turns out by the way they didn't
find they didn't find any well they
found a single one but that's cuz all
the other rooms were drafty he's a je
a stop
the don't let him out wow to to those
who are worried they made it out he he
didn't make it yes he made it out had a
wonderful career yeah absolutely
asteroid by the way they they stormed
this airport there's other videos out
there going up the escalators and this
massive crowd looking for people
actually out on the tarmac next to
planes I think they were ended up
talking to one poor guy that they
thought was a Jew that I don't even know
if he was or not but like this is
literally like Hey we're this this is
Germany in the 1930s more so than I
think we've ever seen outside of that
time period like I I understand there's
anti-Semitism I understand there's
isolated cases but when they literally
storm an airport one of the most secure
places in a country typically they are
looking for people to kill because they
suspected there were people on this
flight from Tel Aviv that were Jewish
what's really bothersome what's really
weird and ironic is that typically
throughout history it was the Christians
that killed the Jews and they would go
to Muslim countries because the Muslims
would give them safe quarter because
they were quote unquote people of the
book so that was typical and now with
this Hamas stuff well in recent history
it's it's the exact opposite yeah but
those usually coincided with Wars for
land because they also killed more
Christians than anyone else too like
people don't realize that you when
you're talking about the Inquisition um
the same thing is is uh if you look at
Islam though they just they just at a
certain point they want to kill all of
them you either convert you're sub
you're subjugated or everybody gets
killed um that is the rule that is the
law of Islam that is what we call what
they call dimude so dagistan is not the
only place by the way uh where people
are are protesting against Israel or
committing Mass crimes against Jews
right now and remember when they said
anti-semitic crimes are on the rise
because Donald Trump of of course it was
his fault I hope I hope if you're out
there Jews remember and this has nothing
to do with the conflict again not one
American Body I think that we should not
be funding both sides of the war but
from the standpoint of moral support
kill every single last member of Hamas
with prejudice No Quarter no mercy
period okay that is my stance that being
said hey Jews in the United States are
are you starting to get the
picture when people say oh Fringe no
hold on a second find me anyone in the
RNC a mainstream conservative sure
there's some neo-nazis out there but
you're talking singled digigit
percentages of a single digigit
percentage right you have the entire
squadh and Our House of Representatives
not to mention other leftists who simply
are espousing anti like anti-jew
rhetoric right now let's just be clear
about that do you do you see the
difference I hope that people do because
I know that Jews in the United States
largely vote uh left and that's because
a lot of them aren't practicing but
around the world and largely the Islamic
World wherever they are a majority there
have been massive protests in support
they will say in support of the people
of Palestine but I have not seen
included massive condemnation of Hamas
it's alarming when you see what's
happening across the
globe fre
that's terrifying turkey look how big
that
is uh-oh Germany's entered the
chat oh jeez largest Islamic country in
the world folks Indonesia yep they also
had a record number of church burnings
in Indonesia and Malaysia they were in
for position for a couple years under
Obama and yeah I feel like it's safe to
say that Jews are not worried about
white supremacy right now some are you
know yeah maybe but it seems like the
larger threat yeah some some still try
and keep that narrative alive find me
any rally the closest you can find is
Charlottesville and it was a bunch of
losers with it was a handful of losers
with tiki torches and one guy with a
Dodge Challenger exactly yeah this is
across the entire Islamic world you had
an entire airport run over in the tiny
country of dagistan to be clear it's not
even close I saw a note was in yeah just
I mean there's so many instances of this
but right now one of them is from
October 27 pramas protests forc Jewish
students to barricade in Copper Union in
New York um that's this is here in the
United States that this is happening
Cornell right now I think there was tons
of anti-Semitic stuff going on at that
University you can look at a timeline
where the University is doing really bad
things just like we saw from Harvard
where students are saying this posters
are being torn down people are very
promos it all stems from Israel
defending itself period and also why is
people why are people not talking about
how Hamas has no interest in a free
Palestine quote unquote No the minute
that the Palestinians are actually a
prosperous Free People they're out of
power they their power relies and Iran's
power relies on chaos and the misery of
the Palestinian people you take that
away and they don't have anything to
fight so we have this abroad but let's
look here in the United States we have a
montage here of a Palestinian
sympathizers and again if you listen to
some of these it would be one thing if
they were to say we absolutely
completely condemn Hamas and terrorism
outright right right but you never
really I shouldn't say never you rarely
see that they usually go what do you
expect if you're being occupied right
also why isn't Hamas considered an
occupation let's be clear in other words
you can condemn the occupation of Israel
if that's how you view it but it's also
an occupation if you look at the way
Hamas shoots their own citizens trying
to flee so here in the United States are
uh some protest free to watch Pro
Palestine Hamas and of course cities
like Los Angeles New York
[Music]
[Applause]
City that just a lazy chant lazy none of
them have ever lived there none of
them have no idea they have no idea what
it's like to live under Hamas
Grand Central
Station hey they said fight like hell
where are they going to be drafted
[Applause]
up oh talking about one solution and wow
je that's a bad idea you can't hide and
one state solution and one solution
sounds like final solution to me look at
[Music]
this no no no if you guys think that
that seems there was a Jew in that car
so it's fine yeah yeah yeah mhm
unbelievable
just there's Jew in that car this is the
United
States this this is the United States
let's put this in context here again it
happens anywhere in the Islamic world
where you you talk about women being
victim blamed right after sexually so
what were you wearing what do you think
happens in a place like Le what do you
think happens in Iran if there's a hate
crime against a Jew it's well were you
looking particularly jewy that day it's
funny doesn't look Jewish
so when we are at remember anyone who
calls for a ceasefire and they go beyond
that saying Jews You Can't Hide one
state solution they're saying the quiet
part out loud yes right what they
usually try and say out loud is
ceasefire which means allow the rape
allow the bombing allow the tunneling
underneath your cities uh to Target and
bomb record number of innocent women and
children and then ceasefire anyone who
says those words ceasefires advocating
for the killing raping kidnapping of
innocent people and supporting Terror
ter
[Music]
ism seriously guys calm it down cease
fire I'm not going to tell you well okay
I'm telling you again I'm not going to
tell you a third
time it just you got off easy yeah it
just doesn't work you don't get to say
ceasefire you don't say oh let's not
punish the crime look wherever Islam uh
achieves or maintains
power this is what happen violations of
Human Rights happen that's that's one of
those things that I know that we had
Rashid T who had the rainbow flag next
to the next to the Palestinian flag
which yeah mhm I know you're thinking
hey you know what they'll get there
they're going to make prog no no even if
you take an exception like Iran and a
70s where you saw some women into a one
piece just give it a decade and a half
then women are killed for not wearing
headscarves you look of course
Afghanistan right you have the Taliban
they said oh we're going to have a lot
of women we're going to have women in
schools remember they said that we're
going to have women in schools we're
going to have scholarships kind of like
a pilg grant but for titties and then
they barred women from going to school
at all they have death by stoning right
you can be buried under a if you go to
Qatar hey clock boyar buried under a
wall we kind of skimmed past that what
yeah I I don't even know why just bury
them anywhere alive well that that seems
cruel I don't necessarily know if they
do it alive I I mean otherwise it's part
of their policy is doing it under a wall
it's like just there just dig a ditch
how many walls do they have in Qatar
remember clock boy went to Qatar because
he couldn't deal with he sued Ben
Shapiro for questioning his Philips
alarm clock put in a suitcase and then
he claimed that he was he was being
persecuted so he went to Qatar yeah
where by the way they punish sodomy with
1 to three years in prison that's just
that's just C they're certainly not at
the point of children on puberty
blockers let alone same-sex marriage
you're lucky if you're not buried under
a wall alive confirmed and if Muslims
have uh sex and they're convicted
outside of marriage and by the way I've
talk I think it's a good thing to wait
until marriage I think it's a good thing
to not be a lying that being said
I don't believe that like Qatar you
should be sentenced to flogging or the
death penalty well hold on why the
difference what what makes it go from
flogging to well you're now getting
how many times you orgasmed yes they
want to he the threat of it yes and also
I think do are you going to get death
penalty or flogging yes but in this
country in this country especially
California you you could lose your house
and be stuck with alimony for the rest
of your life so
fogging lot of you'll take the flogging
but but if you're if you're messing the
pullup and you're you're like ah she
really liked this guy we have to get rid
of him 20 minutes no think that's like
when I was a kid and I wouldn't finish
and my mom would say like they're
starving kids in China when they're
flogging a guy for committing adultery
they're going hey do you know there
there are men in America who have to pay
child support for 18 years I'll take the
fogging I'll take yeah you going to use
a belt or or a branch yeah and by the
way women have even been sens in qar
just to give you an idea uh for engaging
in premarital sex when they're raped if
you go to Turkey that's right right
which is supposedly a more secular
country that's what people pointed to
for a very long time I mean I've been
doing doing this on YouTube for example
since 2006 2009 more political I
remember when everyone used to say well
there are places like turkey and again
you just fast forward a few years right
on Saturday Eran called Israel occupiers
and he talked about the fire that they
would not be able to avoid in uh in in
places like he and let me just really
quickly in front of hundreds of
thousands of people in a pro Hamas they
they don't split hairs on Palestine and
Hamas a pro Hamas yes Gathering he said
that they could enter this war at night
and Israel would never see it coming
like this is a guy who is actively fing
up a crowd of people who don't need any
additional fuel being thrown on that
fire they're ready to go now anywhere
yeah yeah it's it's so I I don't know if
in Saudi Arabia you know you know what
Michigan's going to have you do this I'm
going to go by rote here Saudi Arabia
women weren't allowed to drive maybe
they changed that relatively recently
deaths for Christians across the Islamic
world uh apostasy are subject to deud
meaning that if you're not Muslim you
have to pay a pole tax you have a curfew
there are certain areas where you're not
allowed to visit depending on the
Islamic country you're not allowed to
own land that's Waterfront um there are
different property taxes uh of course
gays being killed through penalty death
penalty that's a matter of policy um
women of course in many countries not
being allowed to vote and then they'll
tell you that they have a lot of female
Representatives or women not allowed to
drive women not allowed to uh gosh their
certain jobs that they're just not
allowed to have things that don't seem
like that big of a deal when you compare
it to the murder and burning alive of
gays but these are standard anywhere in
the Islamic world and here you're
bitching if there aren't enough
scholarships for men to for women to get
into stem programs that they didn't
qualify for anyway and these are the
same people out there saying we need
affirmative action in the United States
go try and go try and explain
affirmative action anywhere in the
Islamic World anywhere in the Islamic
World there are too many there are too
many Arabic or pers whatever it is
Arabic Muslims at this school and we
need more Buddhists or we need more
white Christians we need more Africans
you know black Africans not South Afric
Charlie Stone she really does it for me
but my point is go try explain
affirmative so you Pro you demand
affirmative action here whereas it is
second class citizenry everywhere
everywhere in the Islamic world that
they have achieved the status of running
a government find me any
exception that's the issue not that
there's a small minority not that
there's a small minority of Muslims in
the United States and so oh you know
they're mostly peace they don't have a
choice they have to be peaceful loving
Muslims because we live in a country
where people have rights I get that
they're being eroded but not to the
degree that we're discussing here in the
Islamic world and then when you look
even at small areas in Europe that
become majority Muslim first off remind
me I want to go back to Dearborn and we
can have them bring up an old clip that
I did in 2014 so if we look at places in
Europe so we've gone from Islamic
countries everyone clear okay now we go
to you know little little I guess
Pockets Marseilles Stockholm London
right these places where you have a
bunch of uh you have Islamic sects or
sectors there are no gozone yeah there
are no go zones in London in stockolm
remember remember the the rape in
Cologne on New Year's Eve this happened
there was a such massive migrant rape in
Cologne is Cologne Germany right is
Cologne Germany or I was get was the
other there was a massive rape in Sweden
too yeah wait no but it's colog Germany
uh yes but I think Sweden also also had
a mass rape event they they were not
publishing the details right and this is
just a fact because the vast majority of
the rapes were from immigrants no no
they were not only from immigrants we
wrote about this on the website you can
go read it on lc.com typee in Champagne
they handed out this is New Year's Eve
such a mass rape event they they handed
out do not rape leaflets with actual
images and diagrams of like don't do
this that'll maybe hold hand and we were
fact check pamplet this pamphlet makes a
difference this article I was feeling
kind of rapy and now that I got a
pamphlet in my hand this article went
viral from from our website we we didn't
the exclusive we just happen to be the
people who covered it at that point we
got fact checked by Reuters I believe or
by PolitiFact and they said that the
leaflets this was not the first printing
of the leaflets they were used for
another event therefore it was false but
they handed out to don't rape leaflets
and cologne the very fact that they
exist in the first place Dearborn
Dearborn uh the amount of child
abductions that take place in Dearborn
is UN you know why because women they a
lot of them don't get married by the
state they get married in a mosque do
you know what a man needs to say in
Islam to get divorc just to lick to lick
to lick boom you're gone we had a woman
I believe from Silver Heights Michigan
who was on the show she had to be
anonymous because she was hiding from
her husband who tried to kidnap their
children we had this in Montreal all the
time you would look at the missing
children's reports it wouldn't fit on
the Milk Carton so they would put it on
the side of soda machines but explain
that that's because you as as the father
of your children you have you have full
cust take you just take them you get to
do whatever you want and divorce is
literally say t three times boom done
that's also what allows them to loophole
to have a temporary marriage and get a
on the side so this is something
you can look at what happens in Dearborn
you can look at what happens in these
small pockets in Europe and then of
course always look to what happens in
islamically run countries this I know
what you're saying you're saying well
hold on a second this is hyperbole no
give me one exception one exception of a
majority Muslim nation that has not
committed gross violations of basic
human rights by the way in a selective
manner for non-muslims that's lasted
more more than 10 years ever ever go
ahead I think just in the interest of
being fair before you get criticized
Jordan is pretty moderate because they
are essentially I think Sufi mus pretty
moderate yeah right
now yeah but I think here here's what I
I want they W so moderate when they were
attacking Israel but that's what I want
to go back to something that's really
important term in terms of Hamas
ceasefire and Palestine which these
people never talk about when they're
protesting it's like we can get into the
Islam thing but but do you think doesn't
it count doesn't it mean something where
you want to you're calling for a
ceasefire when it took them two years to
plan what they did on October 7th two
years that was an act of War for two
years it's an act of War I think that's
but my point yes yes and we've talked
but the issue is the Islamic world is
going hey yeah yeah we get it because
because they just hey you talk about
Jordan why Jordan take them Jordan
Lebanon Syria Egypt turkey none of you
none of you because it's a and by the
way there it's also a part of not all
Islam but just to be clear this is why
Pierce Morgan can never get a straight
answer he has these Hamas
Representatives by the way we still have
an invite I don't know if we checked the
proton mail you can come on the show
alongside a member of the IDF I would
love to have you both hash it out maybe
we can solve World Peace here I don't
know but I'm not holding my breath the
reason he can't get a clear
answer there are a lot of Muslims who
write there's tea which means they're
and this is not they're allowed to lie
they're allowed to lie it's a part of
their religion now some people will
argue and say well you're only allowed
to lie you're only allowed to lie and
this is in certain uh certain sects of
Islam and not all of them it's not even
all of you know Shia or Sunni Islam just
to be clear and sometimes there's some
overlap uh you're only allowed to lie if
it's if if it's your life at stake but
then there are a lot of Muslims probably
to the tally of at least tens of
millions maybe not 198 million who
support violence against civilians we
have that poll from last week but at
least the tens of millions who also
believe will not not only lie for you to
not just lose your life but you know
essential living amenities then you're
also allowed to lie if it will convert
people to Islam so let me ask you would
lying about the terrorist activity that
would turn people off because it's a
negative PR campaign it's it's it's not
a good look would lying about that
qualify as bringing people to Islam as
tricking them into Islam do you
understand what Sharia law is this is
also the one place where you're not
seeing this not supporting it at all
just to be clear communist China bad but
Chinese Muslims you know why not because
it's just a religion but because there's
a very there's a very real political
threat from Islam it is a political
prescription when you look at Islam
there is a political prescription for
how laws work it's it's basically
Schoolhouse Rock Schoolhouse Rock I'm
Just a Bill only with killing Jews and
terrorists they tell you what kind of
laws you need to use to govern a truly
Islamic State pleasing to Allah and that
requires subjugation conversion or death
now sub so those are your three choices
under Sharia law death obviously it's
not not a crowd favorite right no you
have conversion okay then you can just I
guess lie and see if and subjugation
what does that come with if you guys
know you know what dimude is that
includes a pole tax that includes a
curfew it includes a whole laundry lists
of dos and don'ts for people who aren't
Muslim if you want to live in this
society and by the way it's just like
someone walking backward and putting
down landm mod so they can execute you
at a moment's notice that is every
Islamic Nation at some point since the
beginning now we can point to some
Christians who we can point to the
Inquisition you can point to if you want
to point to the Crusades and not
acknowledge that they were retaliatory
action in the face of what was going on
at that point um but you can't say every
single group of Christians you can't say
every single place where group groups of
majority Christians congregated did they
kill everyone who was not Christian you
can't it's not an argument you can make
it's not even an argument you can make
for Buddhists it's not an argument you
can make for scientologists it's not an
argument you can make for
Hindus one Islam and that's why you're
seeing it across the entire Islamic
world and pockets of liberalism in the
United States who are who they're just
the crony they're the toy to the they
don't even realize they think that
they'll be killed last not if you're a
gender queer blue-headed tan seexual
lesbian Chain Gang freak Chain Gang well
that that's one of the biggest problems
with how the media is covering in how
the administration seems to be exactly
how the administration seems to be
handling this they're not acknowledging
what really drives these people in these
parts of the world now you're right left
unfettered around the world if you truly
are a Believer not just nominally Muslim
not just kind of going through the
motions Muslim because they're nominal
Christians too you're you're going this
direction this is what the natural
outcome is is taking over and and
basically the only reason that the pole
tax goes away is because they finally
ban it and you're killed or converted so
they take that option away eventually
and it's prescribed in their book and
it's not God doing it like oh the
Christians no no no no no God judges
judges because he is righteous to be
able to do that not saying hey you
Muslim Warrior Go and Kill the Jew
that's hiding behind this Stone over
here this tree over here because they'll
cry out and tell you that that stuff is
happening that's the problem when we
look at these conflicts and try to
evaluate them on economic terms or try
to evaluate them on land terms with
Palestine they don't care about that
this is much bigger for them and they're
happy to play that game in public and
then behind the scenes go they have no
idea what's going on they have no idea
we will never stop going after Jews is
what Hamas says we will never stop going
after these people I don't care what
they give us until every last one is
dead it's in their Charter let me ask
you period okay let's let's let's put it
this way very different situation let's
say and this is where I think people uh
are are misinterpreting the Israel Hamas
uh conflict Israel Palestine conflict
and I've heard people say that it's
weapon manufacturers that are owned by
Jews who have want this war and by the
way I get it that the military
industrial complex that are people who
profit from war to believe that the
Israeli government allowed 1,400 people
to be killed so that they could give out
another weapon to me is okay no no it
does it does start with the eradication
of of Jews from Islam and by the way
Christians are next like you just said
the dimude goes away because you've had
your time if you haven't converted
you're like good news good news the PO
tax is now going to zero today oh
the bad news is you're going to be
burned alive and thrown from a roft up
so let me give you two different
situations and this will give you a
different idea of conflict there is a b
battles for land take place that
resources right that's why I always say
when people say oh what just because
you've been banned from speaking
publicly well people have fought Wars
for Less that's your livelihood only a
lot of us don't have territory like we
used to as an agrarian society of a spot
of digital land so when it's taken away
from you your ability to speak your
ability to make a living online Wars
have been fought for Less I understand
that and that doesn't necessarily L
indicate a battle of Good and Evil
sometimes people just need resources
because they need to live it would be
like coming home you come home your
house is ransacked
okay your your television's gone
computers jewelry all of that and you
make your way up to the bedroom and
someone's still there and you see that
it's a scared poor kid still could have
made better decisions right there are
other options I'm not giving him a pass
but you see that he's scared and he has
maybe a handful of your jewelry he looks
at you and says if you just
just and jumps out the window and he
runs away okay he takes your crap he
runs away all right that's different
you're probably not going to chase him
down and kill him now let's contrast
that you come home this is the kind of
conflict we're we're dealing with you
come home your house has been ransacked
you walk up to your bedroom and at
gunpoint he ties you down to a chair and
says I'm going to come back when your
whole family is here and kill all of
them remember me I'm never going to stop
until everyone in this house is dead
you deal with those two people very
differently and one is an accurate
depiction of how these islamists believe
they are to live how they are called to
act by God it's I'm coming back and
killing every last one of you in the
lipshits household then when I'm done
with that I'm going down to the
McDonald's down the street I'm going to
their household because they're
Christians once we're done with all of
the Jews Christians next because it is a
worldview a religion of global when
people talk talk about the Doomsday
cults of chrisan and they're stupid
right yeah where they're trying to
invite doomsday they'll even talk about
that with Israel right they'll talk
because of the Messiah do you realize
that all of Islam is a doomsday cult
that really we're only going to reach
the end when every single Muslim is
converting every person on Earth you
need to constantly struggle for a global
caliphate and maybe not everyone does
that but 198 Muslims in the world think
it's okay to sometimes kill civilians
and at least 54 million Muslims
according to these polls from Pew
research say it's okay to kill civilians
most of the time you deal with that very
different very differently than a
pickpocket so let me ask you what where
you see this going how you see this
ending and again I would love to hear if
there is an exception Brian says Jordan
I think he's wrong I I think that the
biggest challenge for Islam has always
been how do you can you actually have
separation of church and state it is not
compatible it's not prescribed a
blueprint for how to run your entire
Society it's a theocracy it's absolutely
set up as a theocracy period it's not
set up to coexist with any other thing
governing their people it is a theocracy
that is the biggest uh challenge we have
to get going we've been going late so I
know you're at uh you're at good nights
in November go to brian.com to see that
but I know we'll go to brian.com because
I have to hit the tomorrow the Halloween
Spooktacular contest by the way your
your costume is wildly offensive am I
going as karate tomorrow send in your
send in your
I I have a hiccup that's hurting my
chest I Tred to swallow it I think I'm
having a heart attack so you'll be okay
Instagram or Twitter yeah picture with
your mug use the hashtag Spooktacular do
we want to get into Mike Johnson here on
or do we want to play hipster or hobo
well we have a full segment on who Mike
Johnson is and then we we went late's
hipster or hobo we'll do Mike Johnson
maybe tomorrow the next day he'll still
be unknown to most people then he still
will be unknown to most people but the
more I learn about him the more I I
still don't think about him interesting
yeah but I I I like what I have learned
so if you're watching on YouTube you
shouldn't be if you are right now on
Rumble we are going to continue just hit
that button click it boom join mug Club
none of this happens none of it happens
without you in mug Club period we don't
make any money on YouTube very few live
sponsor reads and I don't know if you
know this but uh we don't get any of
that big Jew money
no say Jewish Jewish what Jew Money
YouTube piss
off
[Music]
look